[Music]
yes
[Applause]
starring roles of the younger
good step back three
Marshwood Sefolosha and clog in the lane
Sefolosha Westbrook comes flying in to
close it down
18 first half
I don't think I wasn't expecting that
for us I did not know you had that bait
no that fat cap to tell fair
[Applause]
the
put him in the basket
[Applause]
struggles with his dribbles pulls back
knocks it down at the puzzle
[Applause]
and I thought he got hit on the release
stepping back now he initiated the
contact but James Harden a really gifted
storm
with the steel just pitched the rant
clean then throws the ball behind
Johnson pulls it away grant running to
the rack
Oh
no word trial nasty
these two all-stars can be produced in
Jeannette Walls pardon
[Applause]
to coach
[Applause]
17-point laws came earlier this week to
Denver looking
[Applause]
what so just did that over a sheikh who
was over seven foot and 275 pounds woman
been famous is behind his
oh that's okay
that is given buildings shud now it says
you know what I'll get behind everybody
in them pika PI
[Applause]
I know they were not supposed to dark
them what happened to boy Adam left
codes you like that content I know you
like that content hit subscribe for more
of it from Bleacher Report